Version spaces is a technique for learning concepts incrementally.
This means that a technique is going to learn from a small set of examples,
that are going to arrive one example at a time. Now we have come across
a different notion of incremental concept learning earlier. In that technique,
we started with a current concept definition.
Then a new example will come about. In this case it's a negative example,
not an arch. And then a new concept characterization would be constructed,
by revising the concept characterization that we began with. The revision was
such that, the new concept characterization was a specialization of
the old concept characterization, such that that the example got excluded. So,
negative examples led to specialization, positive examples led to
generalization, and the ordering of these examples was important.
We want the first example to be a positive example of the concept that we
learned. We want the order to include both positive, and negative examples.
That technique was very useful when there was a teacher available,
who would give you these examples in the right order. Now, the order of
examples was very important in that technique of incremental concept learning.
We want this set of examples to include both positive and negative examples, so
that we can do generalization, and specialization. And we want each example to
differ from the previous concept characterization in only one important feature.
In this case, the only important difference between the new example, and
the current concept characterization is the two bricks touch each other That,
the new example, the first one, the current concept characterization in exactly
one feature, is important. Because it focuses the attention of the learner.
It tells the learner, how to do the specialization, or the generalization, so as
to include the difference, or to exclude the difference. This technique is very
useful if we teachers have a label that can give the examples in a good order,
in the right order, so that effective learning can occur. In that technique of
incremental concept learning. We also consider the rule of background knowledge.
If the current concept characterization is brick, or wedge at the node, and
the learner has background knowledge which tells it that bricks, and
wedges are examples of blocks, then the learner can generalize from brick, or
wedge to a block here. But now we can ask two questions. What happens if these
two factors? The presence of a teacher who gives examples in a particular order.
And the availability of this background knowledge tells the learner exactly how
far the generalize. In general, in learning, deciding how much to generalize.
Is a big problem. Learners tend to either over-journalize,
in which case they come to incorrect answers. Or
they tend to under-journalize, in which case the answer might be correct but
not very useful. If a child comes across a dog that is hooligan, furry, black,
and called Buddy, and the child decides that a dog by definition is.
Four legged, furry, black, and called Buddy. Then that is an example of
under generalization. The conceptual characterization is correct, but
not very useful because we're not transfer to any other dog. On the other hand,
if the trial decides that all four legged, furry animals, are dogs, then
it's an example of over generalization. Because it could also include many cats.
So, the question now becomes what would happen if the examples did not
come in the good order? They came in an arbitrary order. And if this background
knowledge was not available, in that case the agent would have a hard time
deciding how far to generalize. Versions places this technique that are in
a certain conditions, allows the agent to converse to the right generalization.